bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur ceux ci la baisse
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va pas être un sujet qui
le confondent particulièrement c'est à
dire le fait d'être gaucher c'est moche
et ses présents je me suis toujours
demandé pourquoi est ce qu'il y avait
moins de gauche et que deux droitiers
dans la population globale
voilà c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
qui nous est présenté comme étant une
particularité du corps tout comme il ya
moins de roue au moins deux blondes dans
la population globale du corps y avait
moins de personnes qui ont les yeux
bleus je coche un peu toutes les cases
mais bref fred dans la population
globale à l'heure actuelle il ya environ
14% de gaucher et de vos chers donc des
personnes qui écrivent qu'ils utilisent
plus dignement la gauche et c'est vrai
que pourquoi tout simplement
ayassor souvent un argument scientifique
au sens de génétique ou de l'explication
de cerveau gauche cerveau droit
blablabla mais en fait j'ai lu un texte
qui marquent pas les yeux sur le fait
que fait d'être gaucher et notamment
qu'il était bouché dans le monde relève
de pratiques culturelles ce texte que je
vais explicité dans cette vidéo a été
rédigé par un anthropologue français est
du nombre
robert f j'imagine qu'on prononce comme
ça donc notre cher robert qui est
anthropologue est né à la fin du 19e
siècle et a été tué lors de la première
guerre mondiale il avait une trentaine
d'années et c'était un des
anthropologues les plus prometteurs de
sa génération selon ses maîtres
notamment ce monde durkheim et robin m
elle écrit un texte qui s'intitule la
prééminence de l'a23 tu
étude sur la polarité religieuse jeter
un texte qui date de 1909 ça va me ses
premiers écrits majeurs
donc ça montre polak spécialiste des
religions il va nous expliquer comment
la dualité qui vous sur l'arrêt
religion du culte solaire a impacté nos
pratiques et jusqu'à on a raté notre
corps et à changer la face du monde
pourquoi finage signé une majorité de
tentative a réparé revers certes il va
commencer dans son texte par exposer les
arguments qui sont le plus souvent
convoqués pour expliquer la prééminence
des droitiers dans l'action c'est-à-dire
l'argument scientifique de la division
des deux hémisphères du cerveau et du
fait qu'on est gaucher parce que notre
hémisphère droit du cerveau est plus
fort et en fait relève tout simplement
dire au final est-ce que c'est pas
plutôt le fait qu'on est gaucher qui
fait que notre cerveau droit est plus
musclée en quelque sorte en fait revers
certes il va partir du postulat que la
société précède
l'individu est que la société exerce une
action sur un an due au point de
modifier ses pratiques
c'est un des arguments fondateur de la
sociologie tout simplement le fait de
penser que les pratiques sociales ont un
impact sur l'individu par opposition aux
théories individualiste qui pensent que
l'individu fait la société et si robert
tu vas me dire que c'est la société qui
fait d'individus alors regardons comment
s'est dit que de nombreux scientifiques
ont observé que les animaux même visuel
proche de nous c'est bien les singes
sont ambidextre et peuvent utiliser
leurs deux mains de manière égale non
pas une main plus forte que l'autre en
partant de l'observation commençons
ambidextre et va se demander qu'est-ce
qui a fait que les humains sont devenus
des êtres gaucher est automatique et ne
remonte pas très loin pour montrer que
la france chrétienne
à ce moment-là discrimine les enfants
gauchers et les empêche de rédiger de
l'orma dites naturelles delà de la
france et pas du tout l'occident jusque
dans des colonies de l'époque tous leurs
pierres qui relève des puissances
occidentales pour montrer que la
chrétienté d'homère général discrimine
les gauchers et que ce n'est pas la
seule religion à le faire donc explique
que la prépondérance de la main droite
et imposer socialement et culturellement
c'est une obligation qui
iman d'une fête religieuse et ensuite il
va nous expliquer comment le monde c'est
au tour divisée avec une forte
popularité entre la gauche et la droite
et que toutes les actions culturelles et
sociales s'inscrivent dans cet espace
intérieur expliqué que le côté droit
relève du sacré tandis que le côté
gauche relève du profane c'est quelque
chose qu'on observe dans de nombreuses
représentations religieuses et pas
seulement dans la chrétienté c'est aussi
quelque chose qu'on observe chez les
amish tourneur dans la religion soufi
avec ces hommes qui ont la main droite
levée pour recevoir la parole divine et
la main gauche pour la redistribuer vers
le peuple là du côté profane sacré il a
également montré que toute
l'organisation la société repose sur sa
popularité avec dont le côté droit qui
est sacrée mais aussi qu'ils aient flore
qui masculin qui est actif et de l'autre
côté du côté gauche le profane le côté
féminin et la faiblesse d'ailleurs ça
c'est intéressant parce que dans les
statistiques au niveau international on
voit qu'il ya plus de femmes nos chers
que des objets 7 mai avait t on la
retrouve jusque dans le langage puisque
on peut proposer facilement la gaucherie
vannes est maladroit à lanton ratures
les primes aussi une idée force physique
dextérité
il explique aussi que dans notre culture
et de notre religion
il cite d'ailleurs lima où vit le côté
gauche et associe à la mort d'ailleurs
en français ni élections bien connu qui
passe l'armé à gauche c'est à dire il
évoque également le symbole de l'anneau
du mariage qui elle se porte à
l'annulaire gauche pour symboliquement
protéger des tentations qui pouvait nous
écarter de la voiture de nombreux sites
culturels ou religieux et aux
religieuses notamment le fait qu'il faut
entrer du pied droit dans un lieu sain
que la main gauche inspire la terreur et
la répulsion avec par exemple en inde
cette pratique qui existe encore
aujourd'hui qui fait qu'on ne donne pas
quelque chose de la gauche mais explique
aussi que c'est
pour les femmes boscher à la sorcellerie
à des actes c'est un signe en fait la
sorcellerie mais encore beaucoup plus
proche de nous le fait que dans you
curie dit qu'on prête serment perdre at
il conclu tout une remarque sur la
polarité entre le moins touché à la main
droite avec une phrase qui nous dit
ainsi d'un bout à l'autre du monde
humain dans les lieux sacrés où le
fidèle rencontre son dieu comme dans les
lieux maudits où se nouent les pacte
diabolique sur le trône comme à la barre
du témoin sur le champ de bataille et
dans l'atelier paisible du tisserand
partout une loi immuable règles d
attribution de leur invasion de ce
constat qui vécut la polarité entre la
main droite et la main gauche échappe à
la seule chrétienté et éclats où seuls
occident quand il constate que c'est
dans le monde entier dans de nombreuses
cultures dans de nombreuses religions
il émet l'hypothèse que la polarité la
main gauche est commune à tous les
cultes solaire il aimait donc
l'hypothèse que toutes les cultures qui
découlent du culte solaire qu'aurait
cette polarité entre ma main gauche et
la main droite le fait que le soleil se
lève à l'est et se couche à l'ouest ce
répondu explications pour laquelle il y
aurait d'un côté l'optimisme la vie la
force et de l'autre côté là le fait de
décroître la mort avec et nombre
également toutes les difficultés vont
pourvoir dans la nuit et ancien que
roberts conclut son article
avec au final l'idée qu'on menait pas
droitier mais qu'on le devient
[Musique]